as I heard the commissioner speak
reached into my pocket
and I pulled out this photo
this photo is Robert Venable
he's one of my closest friends
when I was a Transit police officer
so Adams loves telling that story but it
turns out it might be a lie the New York
Times is reporting this Eric Adams team
was instructed to create a photo a
picture of the officer was found on
Google it was printed and made to look
worn as if the mayor had been carrying
it for some time including by splashing
coffee on it
joining us now is lizelle the former New
York Congressman as well as former New
York gubernatorial candidate Lee good to
see you does this surprise you at all
yeah I don't think that the mayor needs
to embellish this story at all all
reporting is that he did in fact serve
with his Fallen officer the family
members of this Fallen officer have
spoken out about their relationship with
the mayor so you don't have to go that
next level if the story that's being
reported is true
you have the mayor telling a story
that's inaccurate and using his staff to
help promote the lie it's a little bit
different than you know the mayor saying
that he was a vegan and then news breaks
turns out he eats fish to be quite
candid I don't really care
but when you talk about a story like
this it gets people a little bit more
emotional if you live in New York City
you want strong leadership quite frankly
what has people most concerned right now
in the city is when they see people push
in front of oncoming subway cars they
see the quality of Education being
eroded for their kids in school or they
go to their local store to try to buy
say laundry detergent or maybe
toothpaste you see that it's all locked
up and you see those clothes those
stores closing down so as far as
leadership goes I think that the mayor
just it's a big unforced error you don't
need to do it you have the relationship
with the guy just tell the truth
that's a great point it's not the issue
of the photo it's indicative of
embellishments or duplicity that's
simply been a part of his mayoral uh
term a lot of us had hope that he might
take on New York City and bring it back
to what it was give us give me your
grade your assessment of Eric Adams so
far
he has to go further and it's it's
awkward it's uncomfortable you have to
take on your own party yeah there are
people who are going to go after you
personally I remember when mayor Adams
said that judges should have discretion
away dangerousness when setting cashless
bail and by the way that's absolutely
right Rosie O'Donnell's brother Danny
O'Donnell who's a white liberal
Manhattan Democratic assemblyman went
after the mayor said that dangerousness
is code for Black suggesting that
somehow mayor Adams was racist for
wanting judges to have discretion you
know this has been happening time and
again where people in his own party will
go after him personally but you can't
stand down you have to double down and
triple down what you know is right and
that's the only way to be able to save
this city really regarding the economy
regarding crime and safety regarding
freedom and the quality of Education in
schools it might be awkward
uncomfortable but you have to do it
and then the voters will back you as a
result if you show that backbone which
he has not Lee thank you very much
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else